returning now to the situation in Libya
where we are getting reports that the
internationally recognized government is
saying that is taking complete control
of the capital Tripoli let's bring in
our correspondent mahmoud abdel wahab
who's at the airport in southern tripoli
Mahmud what more do you know will fully
we're here now at the the old
international inactive airport that has
been remember this airport was under
control of half those forces for the
past year now it is fully under control
of the government of national codes
forces after heavy fighting with the
forces loyal to the world Lord Khalifa
Haftar also minute resources with the
government say that the government
forces have been also advancing in other
neighborhoods near the airport including
gas urban area area and also areas near
Taruna city the major stronghold for
Hefner's forces in the west of the
country in fact the government forces
after recapturing this Airport have been
advancing in three main directions
around the city of Taruna which is
actually being decided by the government
forces for months now they say that
every take control of the city after
Hoonah then by by taking tahuna then
after supposes lose the whole west of
Libya with the exception of the city of
vilasa small town of Allah Sabha about
120 kilometers south of the capital
Tripoli just a class just to clarify
Mahmud I'm sorry to interrupt you just
to clarify the internationally
recognized governments are saying that
they're in full control of Tripoli but
you're saying that they are in control
of that Airport in the South that's been
inactive what is the the actual
situation what are they in control of
are they in control of Tripoli
completely as they claim
well that's what the government military
sources say they say they say that they
have recaptured all areas in southern
Tripoli after they pushed Hector's
forces back to the vicinity of the city
of Taruna in fact half those forces have
been now have been driven out of all the
administrative borders of the capital
Tripoli including this Airport which has
been inactive for the past four years as
you know after this forces took control
of this airport last year and from here
they were launching air strikes and also
rockets to target the government forces
locations in many locations in southern
Tripoli and also residential areas in
southern Chile but the government forces
say that there is still a problem facing
them which is the landmines planted by
half those forces and also by the
Russian mercenaries from the Wagner
group who have been fighting alongside
half-turns forces they have been
planting many land mines in the areas
they withdraw from in southern Tripoli
including residential areas and as you
know for that we reported that many
civilians were killed or wounded by
landmines when they try to return home I
mean the the civilians who have been
displaced by the fighting the situation
here in the airport remains very tense
also despite the fact that the
government forces are in full control of
the airport they say that after forces
they still try to target the locations
with grads and motor rockets thank you
for that mahmoud abdel wahab where the
latest air from a southern tripoli